um I've known Adam for a long time man I
always been a great dude stand up dude
what do you think are some of the
biggest like misconceptions about Adam
because I feel like he kind of gets
missed judged a lot people think that
he's a culture vulture but and all in
all bro he giving [ __ ] a chance
and it worked that's what [ __ ] people
up it's not that they feel like that
it's that the truth is he did he took a
crazy ass chance
and it worked that throws everybody off
you know what I'm saying like oh [ __ ] he
didn't have to plan it he didn't have to
do this no the piece is just kinda It
All Happened super organically and super
fast and something kudos to him for
having like that eye for
saying like oh [ __ ] this dude sharp
might be great if he did a podcast try
me [ __ ] A.D neighbors yeah first one's
sitting at two million now that's crazy
first one I ever did with blue jasmine
shout out to you baby wherever you are
hope your career hope everything booming
for you hope you still if you're selling
them clothes holler at me I know you're
still selling clothes